we're actually talking about you know
the transformation
of the human form and not through
technology
but in a cleaner biologically
a way which celebrates natural process
and celebrates the vitality of the
minded
portion of the planet it's an attunement
not this gnostic thing which i evoked
for you which is
you know people used to say of my
grandfather uh where he'd been
was so so where he was was hell
and where he was going was paradise and
he
lived his whole life that way well
that's a gnostic
attitude you know paradise is just ahead
uh i think that paradise is a frontier
of language
of intentional communication
the reason for looking at all these
things for looking at the hallucinogens
and the
alchemy and the mythology and all this
is because these are the materials
present at hand
for an assault on the citadel of true
being you know somewhere here there is a
clue
somewhere here there is something that
we can use it's going to be an obscure
sect a peculiar mantra a strange drug a
bizarre plan
to forgotten teaching a lost alphabet
something that we can
use so that you know i've talked about
the the tantric nature of the point of
view that i'm putting out
tantric in the sense of the definition
of tantra
as the short path taking
seriously the idea that in a single
lifetime a human
being might be able to go vast
distances in the project of spiritual
unfolding that you know we are not
given or fated to
simply incrementally advance ourselves
it is some kind of a lottery i mean
there are
big winners and i'm just very convinced
that the way you enhance your position
in the probability of all of this
is through cognition it will be an act
of understanding
the final act of liberation will be an
act of understanding
yellow i've always felt like that
reality was
a kind of thing that the way you made
progress was you grasped it
in the sense that you grasp a
mathematical
or geometric proposition or something
like that
but it's something which once understood
on some level clears the way to advance
a very short distance so that's what
you're always trying to do is create
this lexical space
of presumed understanding
and and live inside that
the basic notion here i think is an idea
of radical freedom
i mean this is not a cult of terence
mckenna it is not a drug cult
it's a cult of curiosity if it's a cult
of anything
and what you're supposed to understand
when you come out of here
that an open mind is a very
precious thing and it should never be
given away
perhaps ever certainly never lightly
the truth can take care of itself it
does not require
your belief the truth need not be
treated as fragile you can beat on the
truth with ball peen hammers
and it will do just fine thank you so
it one should be respectful in the
presence of
truth but not
cowed or awed
or something like that the truth wants
to be appreciated it wants to be
known it can take care of itself
belief is toxic all belief
don't believe in anything live in the
presence of the
felt fact of immediate experience
everything beyond that is conjecture
in contemporary society we're always in
the past
and in the future but what is real are
feelings and feelings attain a nexus
only in the moment only in the moment
so you know explore the edges
keep your logical razors sharp trust
nothing that you haven't verified for
yourself
and my faith
is that the universe will
take you in and share with you its
meaning
and its intent and
its conclusion
[Music]
you